-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you very much.
-I'm so happy to have you.
Been a fan of yours
for a very long time.
-Thank you.
-And I want to ask
about "The Crown,"
because I think there's probably
this unfair perception
that most Americans have
that all British people
are obsessed with
the crown and the monarchy
Not the case.
-No.
I sort of barely thought
about them for most of my life
-Yeah.
-And, yeah, then I --
Yeah, then I had to actually
be one of them.
So I thought I better
read about it a bit.
-Yeah.
I mean, my background was
sort of small-R republican
My mum would actively not watc
the Queen's speech
on a Christmas morning.
So, yeah, I had no idea
about them at all.
So, yeah, what
could possibly go wrong?
[ Laughter ]
-I always wonder,
because, you know,
it's very strange.
This is both a historical drama,
but a lot of the key players
are, you know,
they're still alive.
-Yeah.
-Do you think to yourself,
"Are they watching?"
And, also, do you
want them to watch?
-It's a very mixed thing.
Part of you wants them to watch,
but also part of you
is terrified.
I mean, I sort of can't imagin
the Queen and Prince Phili
sort of, you know,
Netflix and chilling.
-Yeah.
-I don't...
-I don't know.
-I didn't think about that
Even if it was on BBC,
I would think they're
probably not watching.
But the fact that it's like,
"What's our log-in?"
-Yes.
-"Where..."
"I forgot the log--"
-It's a generational thing
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So I think you're probably --
you might be in the clear.
-In the clear.
-Both you and Olivia Colman,
and Helena Bonham Carter,
you all also have
this interesting job
ahead of you,
where you're taking over parts
from other actors.
Matt Smith, who was wonderfu
in the first two seasons -
did you spend a lot of tim
watching him?
-I've never heard of him.
-No. I think that's best.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Do you try to watch
what he did?
Or do you think to yourself,
like, "Oh, that'll only
get in the way of
what I choose to do?"
-No, like you, I really love
the first two seasons.
I loved what Matt did.
So, yeah, it was actually
kind of an amazing resourc
to go back
to those first two seasons
and watch,
and then sort of combine tha
with, you know, the real person.
It was like 80/20.
-Yeah, that's pretty good.
I think 80/20's good.
That's what I got
from your performance.
-Okay, thanks, buddy.
-I was like, "That's
about 80/20 right there."
-Okay.
-A lot of corgis.
-Yes.
-So, there's
a lot of on-set corgis.
-Well, there are
two on-set corgis.
-Just only two?
-Yeah.
And there's a boy corgi
and a girl corgi.
-Gotcha.
-The girl corgi
is quite mischievous.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, she very rarely sort of
stays where she's meant to stay.
-Yeah.
-And when the girl corgi
is there, the boy
gets quite mischievous, too.
So, often, you have to, like
remove the girl corgi.
And the boy corgi then
is quite well-behaved.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-Was there any part
of playing this role
make you long for a life where
you could live as a royal?
-No. No part of me would want to
be a -- absolutely none, yeah.
-It does seem
pretty just depressing.
-Well, just, I mean, obviously
hugely privileged.
But I just --
You go into a lot of rooms
people are kind of
tongue-tied I imagine.
So just this sort of sheer
weight of quantity of chat..
-Yeah.
-...is heavy, I think.
Small talk.
-Right, yeah.
Everybody is going to leav
and talk about
how they met you.
-Yes.
-And you're never going to
go home and tell anybody
who you met.
-No. I imagine they sort o
look at you, like, sort of this.
-Yeah.
-And I imagine that's sort of,
yeah, an odd way
to spend your day.
-I also think giant rooms
sound really cool
until the minute
you're sitting in one.
And then you're like,
"This is really cold."
-Yeah, "Can we bring everythin
in a bit?"
-I'd love to just get it in?
Also, I feel like you --
if you were in, like,
Buckingham Palace,
you're like, "Oh, my God,
I need way more pictures
to put up on the wall
and stuff."
-I mean, I hear anecdotally,
they kind of hate
Buckingham Palace.
-Yeah.
-That's why they sort of
constantly go out to sort of
Scotland and all the other ones.
-Yeah. I mean, I guess
that's the thing.
I've always said, if you hav
a Buckingham Palace,
make sure you have other places.
-Yeah, exactly.
How other palaces?
-You got to have
a few other palaces when you
get tired of your palace.
That is just --
-That's a good rule.
-That's one of
the hard, fast rules.
[ Laughter ]
You stayed with one of your --
I heard you were getting wor
done on your place.
You were staying with
one of your costars --
Helena Bonham Carter.
How was that?
Did you know each other well
You must have.
-Well, we've gotten to
know each other on the show.
Yeah, she's a wonderful woman.
And she very kindly took me in
in my hour of need.
I sort of had a shortfall
for a few weeks.
Yeah, we've been doing a sort of
deep meta kind of "Crown,"
where I sort of live
with Princess Margaret.
-Yeah.
-Sort of like
an alternate reality.
-We stayed in the accents
and everything.
-Oh, great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It was bizarre.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But as actors,
you have to, yeah.
-I mean, it's very important
to do this sort of work.
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, I hope you can se
the results in the show.
-Absolutely.
I think we all did.
The Queen texted me.
She loved it.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, I first -- I think
I first saw you in "Rome."
-Oh, wow, yeah.
-I loved you in "The Terror.
-And very serious stuff.
and then you turned up
in "Catastrophe,"
which is a wonderful show,
created by Rob Delaney and
Sharon Horgan.
And another great show,
called "This Way Up."
These are comedies.
which I hadn't seen you in
And yet, even in the comedies,
it seems like
you play it very serious.
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I'm essentially
not a very funny person.
[ Laughter ]
So the only way I can be funny
is if someone brilliant
like Sharon Horgan
or Aisling Bea
write me funny things to say
And then I keep my face
quite still.
And I say the line.
And apparently it's funny.
-That's great.
-That's how it works.
-And when they
first came to you,
I mean, I think sometimes
there are dramatic actors
who, when they
get a chance at comedy,
they think, "Oh, my God, great
Now I can do all these
funny voices I have."
Did they come to you
and specifically say,
"Just do exactly what you do
in the serious things?"
-No, no, I mean,
I have my faults,
but I have a very clear sens
of how funny I am.
[ Laughter ]
So I know --
I know that I need their help.
and I'm very grateful to the
for, yeah, making me
occasionally funny.
-Oh, great. It pays off great.
You're wonderful in both.
And thanks so much
for being here.
It's really great to meet you.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
Tobias Menzies, everybody.